Could you Dr. Zakia to start the
proceedings simply tell our viewers what
are the recommended acts during Ramadan?
>> Alhamdulillah.
Normally all the acts that are
recommended during the normal days are
also recommended during the month of
Ramadan except those acts which break
the fast.
But there are specific acts which have
been recommended by a prophet especially
during the month of Ramadan and some
acts are encouraged more during the
month of Ramadan and there are many of
them. I'll try and list as many as I
can. The first is having sour.
You should not neglect. Number two is
having sour as late as possible just
before the break of dawn. Third is
having an earlytar as early as possible
just after sunset. The fourth is having
dates and water when you break the fast.
Fifth is saying the recommended duas
after you break the fast. And
the sixth is that when you break the
fast, it is preferable you invite other
people especially the poor people. And
these six inshallah I'll be discussing
tomorrow. The other things which are
recommended by the prophet is number one
that we should do as many good deeds as
possible during the month of Ramadan.
Number two we should be more generous in
the month of Ramadan. Number three that
if someone tries to provoke you, you
should not get angry but you should say
I'm fasting. I'm fasting. Number four,
we should use the sew that the tick.
Number five, that if possible should
perform um during the month of Ramadan.
Number six, should try and acquire as
much knowledge as possible. Read the
Quran along with the translation. We
have to read the hadith, read the
Islamic books. Number seven, we have to
attend as many Islamic programs as
possible, lectures, seminars to increase
Islamic knowledge. Number eight,
we should
watch Islamic programs maybe on the
video, watch Islamic cassettes, hear
Islamic audio tapes of scholars so that
we increase our knowledge. Number nine,
we have to be happy throughout the day.
We should not look gloomy. Number 10, we
should look with other people. Number
11, we should be extra good to our
family. Number 12, we should
That means ponder and think on it. And
number 13 is that
we should see to it that we try and
forgive people's faults. And there are
other acts which the prophet also
recommended which inshallah we'll be
dealing in detail in the other days. For
example, the prophet said that we should
specially be careful that all our
compulsory salah we should offer in
congregation as far as possible in the
mosque. Number two is we should offer as
much as sunnah salah as much as naw.
Number three, we should supplicate as
much as possible to Allah subhanaa tala.
Number four, we should ask for
forgiveness because this is the month of
forgiveness. Number five, we should
recite as much Quran as possible. Number
six, we should offer tarawi. Number
seven, we should specially
in the last 10 days we should decry.
Number eight is we should do
in the last 10 days if possible and
number nine we should give zakat if we
have not given number 10 is that we
should do our own self-improvement as
much as possible number 11 seek
number 12 is isla of the other Muslim
brothers and number 13 is dawa to the
non-Muslims so these in short are the to
topics which I have listed which are
especially recommended in the month of
Ramadan.
>> Subhan Allah. A lot of topics we've got
to get through Dr. Zakia. And I hope and
I trust in Allah subhana wa ta'ala that
we can get as much benefit out to the
viewers and to ourselves first and
foremost as well. Sure.